victoria woodhull challenged almost
everything that katherine beecher stood
for
beecher was a best-selling author who
encouraged women to use their influence
within their homes
in contrast victoria woodhull became the
first female broker on wall street the
first female editor of a weekly
newspaper and the first woman to run for
president
woodhull preferred action over feminine
influence in 1871 the two women met once
and let's just say it didn't go well
they publicly opposed each other
we can learn a lot about victoria
woodhull from this portrait
sometime soon after she moved to new
york city in 1868 she went to the
photography studio of the famous matthew
brady
by then many celebrities including
abraham lincoln had come to matthew
brady's studio
when whittle visited brady she wore a
top hat with a bow and military style
jacket the unbuttoned jacket allows room
for her breasts and even seems to
suggest that she's wearing men's
clothing
a faux bow tie completes the ensemble
political cartoons mocked women's rights
activists as masculine and here she is
dressing up in manly clothing
additionally her pose is far from lady
lake woodhull leans against a wooden
desk and an unladylike pose she's
appropriating the costumes and poses
from caricatures of political women and
is demonstrating her power over these
gender norms and attracting a bit of
publicity
her sister tennessee was known for
wearing men's suits too at their
brokerage office woodhull is teasing the
many americans who feared that political
women would become masculine
the photograph confirmed the fears of
americans concerned that political women
challenge the accepted social order
woodhull stands out because she directly
challenged american political cultural
and religious norms and became an
incredibly controversial figure she
mostly worked on her own to create
change and less often collaborated with
other reformers to coordinate a broader
movement
woodhole won powerful allies but she
also lost them we celebrate many of her
achievements today but the overwhelming
majority of 19th century americans
viewed her story as a cautionary tale
for women
in 1838 woodhull was born victoria
claflin in homer ohio
she's the first of the women we've
discussed who was born in the midwest
the united states had already expelled
many native peoples from their lands and
sent them westward and they settled
their own citizens to claim the land
woodhull was born just after the panic
of 1837
during the economic depression that
followed for several years
her family lacked financial security
which significantly shaped her
upbringing
roxanna hummel claflin gave birth to
victoria her seventh child and named her
after the new queen victoria in britain
in 1846 she had her 10th and final child
tennessee celeste claflin tennessee
would later join in on many of
victoria's adventures
at the time of victoria's birth the
claflins had seven children and no
reliable income
victoria's father ruben claflin owned a
mill that he never operated
nonetheless he insured it against fire
for four thousand dollars when it burned
down soon after locals suspected that
claflin who was known for his heavy
drinking burned it himself
he and his family had to leave town
together they moved around for years
trying to make enough money to survive
victoria's father bottled and sold a
so-called medicine called life elixir
that contained alcohol and the opiate
laudanum
it might seem surprising that such a
concoction was legal but there was
little regulation over medicines
the family also made money by forcing
victoria to work
she only had a few years of formal
education
at eight years old victoria started
preaching
child preachers were popular in ohio in
the aftermath of the second grade
awakening the claflins charged admission
to see their daughter speak
so victoria learned how to perform she
also learned to be resourceful to
support herself the rise of spiritualism
in the late 1840s provided a starting
point
unlike most traditional organized
religions spiritualism offered women
leadership opportunities
anti-slavery reformers like william
lloyd garrison women's rights activists
like amy post and many other influential
americans embraced spiritualism
for example in 1848 the year of the
famed seneca falls convention the 11 and
13 year old fox sisters became famous
for interacting with spirits they asked
questions and spirits would respond by
wrapping on walls tables or other pieces
of furniture the sisters asked the
spirits to questions to predict futures
and answer detailed questions about
audience members while some opposed
spiritualism for many the practice
coexisted with traditional forms of
religion
the claflin saw a new opportunity to
make money ten-year-old victoria and her
younger sister tennessee could do this
victoria was already a master performer
tennessee started winning fame for
having dreams that seemed to predict the
future victoria went into trances during
her performances
sometimes their father would starve them
to ensure that they did what he wished
later in her life victoria suggested
that he sexually abused them too
by the time she was 15 victoria wanted a
new life
a local 28 year old doctor named canning
woodhull proposed to her
and she accepted she must have been
desperate to leave her family and might
have hoped for more stability
unfortunately her new husband like her
father was often drunk and had affairs
with other women
she had two children with him but she
did not have a good life
in 1865 the same year that the civil war
ended they decided to divorce
she kept his name
if you think getting divorced even 50
years ago was unusual imagine how
controversial it was in the mid 19th
century in fact in some states it was
barely legal
woodhull supported herself by performing
in theaters and as a clairvoyant
she and her children moved to ottawa
illinois to live with her family
victoria and her sister tennessee became
famous for telling fortunes
they sold a healing elixir just like her
father had years earlier and likely even
ran a brothel
in 1864 one of their patients died and
the family was accused of selling fake
medicine
tennessee was even indicted for
manslaughter but she and her family
disappeared by the time an arrest
warrant was drawn up in spring 1865.
nothing ever came of the charges
woodhole moved with her family to
chicago and then to st louis where she
met colonel james harvey blood who had
fought for the united states during the
civil war
here's the problem he was already
married with children it didn't matter
in 1866 he divorced his wife and married
victoria
eventually in 1868 the couple moved to
new york city and tennessee joined them
they wanted a new start
notably president lincoln and his wife
mary todd lincoln had hosted seances in
the white house to communicate with
their dead son
fortunately for the sisters after the
civil war the spiritualist movement was
thriving more than 600 000 people had
died during the civil war and many
wanted a way to communicate with their
loved ones
victoria and tennessee became
clairvoyance the pair relayed stories of
their visions held seances and told
fortunes they sold a new version of
their laudanum-laced life elixir as well
as early forms of birth control
both have been prostitutes and likely
still were they became friends with
madames who managed elegant brothels
with a clientele of wealthy powerful
white men these women paid close
attention to conversations about the
latest investment strategies
the sisters secured an introduction to
commodore cornelius vanderbilt one of
the richest men in america
he made his fortune by investing in
steam ships and railroads they shared
messages from his deceased mother with
him as well as financial tips supposedly
from the spirits
tennessee had an affair with him too by
1870 they became the first female
stockbrokers on wall street and founded
woodhull claflin and company
the sisters earned a percentage from
vanderbilt's transactions they had other
clients too including society ladies
the sisters must have been relieved to
have a reliable source of income they
were securing credibility and power too
at the same time post-civil war new york
city hosted important debates about the
nation's future
in 1866 activists formed the american
equal rights association to win equal
rights for women and black people
however reformers split over the 15th
amendment women's rights and free love
the 15th amendment prohibited voter
discrimination based on race which
effectively gave black men access to the
ballot
it passed in 1870 but some reformers
especially women's rights activists were
furious that the amendment did not
enfranchise women too
reformers split into two groups
one back to the 15th amendment however
the other organization led by susan b
anthony campaigned against the law
woodhull started working with the
leaders in these activist circles
she attended her first women's voting
rights convention in 1869.
in april 1870 she announced that she
would run for president during the next
election in 1872
she wrote a letter to the new york
herald to announce her choice
she declared while others of my sex
devoted themselves to a crusade against
the laws that shackle the women of the
country i asserted my individual
independence and i proved men and
women's equality by successfully
engaging in business
wood hall became the nation's very first
woman to run for president but she had
no chance of winning
she was 34 and the constitution requires
presidents to be at least 35.
still woodhall claimed political power
by running for office rather than
working with suffragists to ask for it
the following month victoria and
tennessee launched woodhull and
claflin's weekly to promote woodhull's
political platform the sisters became
the first women to edit a weekly
newspaper
woodhull traveled to washington d.c to
lobby for a women's voting rights
amendment representative benjamin butler
of massachusetts invited her to address
congress since men had positions as
political leaders and could vote men
like butler were crucial advocates of
women's voting rights in january of 1871
she delivered a speech to the judiciary
committees of the senate and house of
representatives
woodhull was particularly prepared to be
a good public speaker
she had been a performer for years as a
child preacher stage actor and
spiritualist leader
i can imagine her brimming with
confidence as she stepped out in front
of this group of powerful men who
probably intimidated many
she argued that under the constitution
men and women should be equal
woodhull told them the male citizen has
no more right to deprive the female
citizen of the free public political
expression of opinion than the female
citizen has to deprive the male citizen
thereof
while some suffragists argued that women
were more moral than men whittle
stressed equality between the sexes she
declared women are the equals of men
before the law and are equal in all
their rights as citizens
and even noted that men and women of all
races should vote
the most important argument in woodhull
speech is that she made the case that
women already had the right to vote as
citizens
congress or perhaps the supreme court
needed to annul state laws that put
voter restrictions in place in order to
honor the constitution
frank leslie's illustrated newspaper
printed an illustration of woodhull
addressing the judiciary committee
most newspapers still only featured text
but frank leslie's was one of two
newspapers famous for having
illustrations
they did not have the technology to
reproduce photographs but they could
cheaply print engravings and in an era
without the internet you can imagine my
readers would be curious to see
portraits of political and cultural
figures landscape scenes of faraway
places and images of new inventions the
editors must have thought their readers
would be curious to see this unusual
moment for themselves women rarely
addressed congress
in the engraving woodhill stands and
reads her address
around her male politicians listened to
her arguments women joined the group but
they were interested citizens not
congressional representatives the woman
who sits next to her is likely supposed
to be tennessee
behind woodhull we can identify
elizabeth katie stanton with her white
curly hair
the artist might not have actually even
been at the meeting and it's unlikely
that any photographs were taken
photographs still required sunlight to
produce and they also required at least
several seconds of stillness from
everyone in the scene
the engraver probably based the
representation of these women on their
public portrait photographs which was a
common practice
today when we see an image like this one
we might be impressed by woodhull some
americans might have felt that way in
1871 but many others would have felt
appalled angry and anxious
in their minds women were supposed to be
private domestic figures just as
katherine beecher advised
not political leaders like men
woodhull recognized that women who
occupy the roles usually held by men
made people nervous which is why she did
things like take the portrait we
discussed at the beginning
woodhull and her ideas became popular
among some women's rights leaders she
delivered her address to the judiciary
committee on the same day of a suffrage
convention in washington d.c
elizabeth katie stanton and susan b
anthony were so impressed that they
invited her to speak
additional speaking invitations followed
and she gained a following
woodhall had argued to the judiciary
committee that all citizens had the
right to vote and activists adopted this
idea susan b anthony wrote to her bravo
my dear woodhull i feel new life new
hope that our battle is to be short
sharp and decisive go ahead bright
glorious young and strong spirit
suffragist called this new legal
strategy the new departure and planned
to force the courts to rule on whether
voting was a right of citizenship
suffragists across the country
coordinated a plan to vote in the
presidential election of 1872.
they wanted to be prevented from voting
or even be arrested so that the courts
would have to rule on this question
woodhull promoted this plan after all
she planned to run for president in
1872 perhaps she hoped the women would
vote for her
but within the year the suffragists
whose admiration she had just won
shunned her
here's what happened
when they first met woodhull many
suffragists didn't know much about her
or her past but she soon became the most
famous or shall we say infamous for it
especially for her divorcing her husband
having sex outside of marriage and
promoting free love her ideas about free
love were a precursor to the free love
movement of the 20th century
woodhull believed people should marry
for love or perhaps not even marry at
all
they should be able to divorce if they
are no longer in love
even more controversial she argued that
sex did not have to be confined to
marriage and evidence suggests that she
practiced that lifestyle
women deserve to control their own
bodies and decide if they were willing
to risk getting pregnant she believed
that women should be able to say no to
sex with their husbands don't forget
that marital rape was not seen as a
crime until the
1970s
women were expected to submit to their
husbands desires
whittle declared marriage sexual slavery
and suggested that i was akin to
prostitution
many americans including some suffrage
leaders started to disapprove of her
they didn't like her ideas about
equality that she was running for
president and that she had such an
unconventional lifestyle
in february 1872 just a year after a
fairly positive portrayal of her and
frank leslie's illustrated newspaper
harper's weekly the main illustrated
competitor to frank leslie's printed
their own engraving of woodhull thomas
nast one of the most famous cartoonist
represented woodhall as a devil and
labeled her mrs satan she has horns
large black wings and a sign that says
be saved by free love
woodhill ignores the impoverished family
behind her rather than helping this poor
woman who suffers because of her
husband's drinking and the burden of
having to help her family nas suggests
that woodhall just wants to promote her
scandalous free love ideas
in reality woodhull advocated for
policies to represent working poorer
people after all she was one of them
at first leading activists like
elizabeth katie stanton susan b anthony
and catherine beecher's half-sister
isabella beecher hooker stood by
woodhull stanton was disgusted by
attacks on woodhull for her disregard
for feminine norms
in 1871 she wrote to fellow women's
rights leader lucretia mott she said we
have had women enough sacrifice to this
sentimental hypocritical prating about
purity this is one of man's most
effective engines for our division and
subjugation
stanton continued he creates the public
sentiment builds the gallows and then
makes us the hangman for our sex
stanton wanted women to stop holding
each other to men's ideals for other
women she wanted them to stop taking
each other down susan ultimately
concluded if victoria woodhull must be
crucified let men drive the spikes and
plate the crown of thorns
in 1872 woodhull decided to organize a
convention and start her own political
party to launch her presidential
campaign
the equal rights party nominated her for
president and listed the famed civil
rights and women's rights advocate
frederick douglass for vice president
however frederick douglass did not
attend the convention and did not learn
about this nomination until later
woodhull's political platform endorsed
women's votes free love labor reforms
and spiritualism
whittle enjoyed support from activists
for a while but that shifted as they
found out about her past
she's still financially supported and
even lived with her first ex-husband
canning woodhull
while she was in a relationship with her
second husband
the public also didn't like her support
of marxism and her attacks on capitalism
and wealth inequities
she started losing supporters and
woodhull claflin and company started to
lose clients
even stanton changed her mind after
woodhull exposed the late 19th century's
greatest scandal the beecher tilton
affair
in 1872 just before the presidential
election she named the famous and widely
respected preacher henry ward beecher as
an adulterer he was the brother of
catherine and isabella too
woodhole published an article about his
affair in her newspaper she told
everyone that beecher and one of his
parishioners elizabeth tilton were in a
relationship plus elizabeth tilton was
married to the prominent reformer and
editor theodore tilton
woodhull's revelation became a scandal
for beecher's church and the reformed
community as a whole
especially for women's rights supporters
beecher was president of the american
women's suffrage association and theater
tilton elizabeth's husband supported
suffrage ii
woodhull exposed the scandal to try and
convince beecher and her fellow
americans to support free love henry
ward beecher was already rumored to have
had affairs with many women
so he was clearly already practicing
free love just like victoria
woodhull proclaimed the hypocrisy of
henry ward beecher's actions she
declared my judges preach against free
love openly practice it secretly
woodhull opposed the sexual double
standard for men and women
the sisters newspaper was a sensation
it sold quite well for several months
and led to paid lecture opportunities
too
but it also led to charges against
woodhull for sending obscene materials
through the mail
she and her sister were arrested and
they spent election day in jail
woodhull lost the presidential race this
was the year that susan b anthony and
sojourner truth cast their ballots and
soon afterward the supreme court ruled
that female citizens did not all have
the right to vote
woodhole's new departure argument failed
she also lost many friends catherine
beecher condemned woodhull in the press
though her half-sister isabella beecher
hooker thought woodhull was right about
her brother's affairs and defended her
for much longer
newspapers had headlines about the
beecher tilton affair for years
henry ward beecher was investigated by
his church but they ultimately
exonerated him
theodore tilton then filed a legal suit
against beecher in brooklyn to recover
damages for the affair it was another
media sensation the jurors ended up
being deadlocked despite the evidence
they couldn't condemn the famous
preacher
theodore and elizabeth tilton and
woodhull were effectively ruined by this
scandal but beecher retained his
respectability
anthony stanton and fellow suffrage
leaders shunned woodhull she had refused
to fall in line behind them suffragists
wanted a political revolution but their
rejection of woodhull made the limits of
their vision clear
they needed to moderate their demands to
win public support
the woodhull episodes stressed the power
of the press they needed to appeal to
the public not to give them fodder for
ridicule
they needed leaders with wide appeal to
win
backers rejected from new york society
with little options woodhull reinvented
herself again
she realized that women had few options
they couldn't afford to be hypocrites
like henry ward beecher
in 1877 she set off for england with
tennessee and her family
woodhull rejected free love and her
activist life she decided to create a
more respectable public image for
herself one that even katherine beecher
might have approved of
in 1883 she married the banker john
bitoff martin and tried to cement her
position as a lady
tennessee also married a wealthy man and
embraced her new role as a wife
in 1892 she started working with her
daughter named zula maud on a journal
called the humanitarian which promoted
eugenics a field that aimed to
supposedly improve the human race by
choosing who they thought was good
enough to reproduce
as you can guess this organization
promoted white christians at the top of
this imagined social hierarchy the
publication emphasized her conservatism
and respectability
in 1893 the year after they started the
humanitarian woodhull and her new
husband sued the british museum for
libel because they had books about the
beecher tilton affair
she had once been proud of her work to
shine a light on sexual hypocrisy but by
then she pretended she had nothing to do
with it
even so much of british elite society
wanted nothing to do with her in 1901
she stopped working on the journal to
focus on philanthropy
in 1927 she died in england at the age
of 88.
she lived as a gentlewoman for 55 years
after she ran for president in 1872
although she ended her life living by
widely accepted feminine social norms
whittle also provided an exciting model
for challenging them
her choices did not catch on in 19th
century america but i have to wonder
what she thought about the changing
world of the 1920s
by the time she died many women in the
united states and britain had the right
to vote
love was a bit freer and gender norms
were far less strict
you